there's a father of a young elite
athlete who reached out to us
uh the the young man in question
um and he said that we could even use
his his name and and the the place where
he's competing and such but i'm i'm not
going to do that um
but this is this 12 year old is
nationally ranked highly nationally
ranked in cross country and in fact won
a big race today
his father has basically been told that
um
unless he vaccinates his extraordinarily
healthy athletic young son who is
winning competitions and highly
nationally ranked um he's
not going to be able to compete anymore
he's gonna have to leave the
the
uh the team the organization that he is
currently part of
and the father says in my view these
kids not only have little risk of
exposed to covet but also they are among
the healthiest group you can find
despite that the club is mandating
everyone to get the vaccine
yeah it's not just your view that's
actually what what the actual data show
if you have young
young athletes who are so capable that
they are actually so athletic that they
are winning competitions
they are at little risk
and
exactly that among the healthiest group
that you can find
um
he says of him and his wife the parents
of this of this young man this young
person it is not like we are uneducated
um i'm not gonna i'm gonna allied some
of these details but um one of them is
an md with a master's in public health
one of them's got some master's degrees
in engineering he says we know how to
read data and we recognize tampered data
finally he says i'm not going to
vaccinate my kid but i wonder how to
leave the club with maximum noise to let
everyone know how crazy and fanatic
these people are becoming any
recommendations suggestions or help
if you'll riff a little bit while i find
this screenshot so i can show it sure i
i would i keep trying to figure out how
to phrase the issue my sense is that i
understand why there was confusion
around the wisdom of
vaccinating
in older age groups and really
from the beginning the case was clearest
as you got to the oldest age group and
it became less and less clear as you got
towards young healthy people who tend to
endure covid very well
and who would also gain natural immunity
this is another place where
[Music]
i believe the tide has turned people are
no longer
ready to accept the idea that the
vaccine immunity is superior because so
much evidence suggests exactly the
opposite is true of course theoretically
that had to be the case but
the the question is as we get to these
young people
i really want somebody to explain a
comparison
between the risks that they experience
from the vaccines extrapolated to what
must be the plan going forward versus
the risk that they experience from the
disease itself right especially if you
were to do something like say hey we
need to make sure all young people have
you know no vitamin d deficiency right
that would take a tremendous amount of
the tiny risk that exists for very young
people and eliminate it presumably
there's a really good chance that elite
cross-country runners
um are are pretty good on their vitamin
d as well even though um this guy lives
pretty far north but you know they're at
their athleticism their athletics is
running around outside outdoors yep
exactly and presumably um running around
uh not heavily clothed so as not to
preserve to capture too much heat right
so anyway it's a good situation for
generating vitamin d but the question is
look if somebody was gonna you know
pressure you to vaccinate your kid you
should be able to say well all right how
much risk is there for a kid my age in
their state of health from the disease
itself what is the risk that they will
catch it
what is the risk to them if they do
catch it versus
what is the risk from the vaccines and
what is the risk from each of the
boosters going forward and how many do
you expect they will need to take
because one of the factors here
is if you know and again i'm not signing
on to the idea that this is necessarily
endemic and we'll never get rid of it i
really don't know that we know enough to
think that yet given the odd origin that
this virus likely has
but
if this is going to be a permanent
fellow traveler of humanity then maybe
we are talking about annual or bi-annual
boosters each of which would carry an
adverse event risk which could be
entirely obviated by a
case of kovid that was
successfully treated or so mild that it
didn't matter
so the question is
and i'm not saying this is not a public
health
uh conclusion but from the point of view
of the individual child and for each
parent
protecting that individual child as best
as possible ought to be the priority
right
society does not get to tell us
sacrifice your child so that old and
firm people suffer somewhat less risk of
covet even though there isn't even
particularly strong evidence that very
young people are playing that role in
the pandemic in the first place but
even if it were true there would need to
be a national conversation akin to is it
time for a draft right exactly is is
this a time in which our children need
to be forced to sacrifice health or
safety or something and we haven't had
that conversation in fact it's all been
disguised as if this is being done for
the kids
but
the question is what is the comparison
between
the risk of covid admittedly a serious
disease but much less serious for young
people in fact not very dangerous at all
if you're sufficiently young and healthy
right
compared to
boosters going forward that apparently
need to be redone every six months right
i don't think that comparison is
favorable to the idea of let's do this
for the kids it's a very different
question natural immunity lasts longer
it's broader it's not just to
the stuff on the spike protein
and um
and children
healthy children
don't die
of coping yep
children can obtain natural immunity
and be protected for far longer then
even a fairly long series of boosters
would protect them and
you know note the following thing we
have
the claim the vaccines are safe and
effective how effective well much less
effective than they were initially
claimed because they
the
protection what protection exists decays
very very quickly
but
nonetheless
we are told that they are safe
what are we told they are safe based on
based on a very short
limited in scope trial
what has happened after that trial the
system that is designed to capture a
signal of adverse events badly designed
but a system that is designed to capture
that signal has captured a signal that
is unprecedented and we are told to
ignore it that it doesn't mean anything
which okay let's take them at their word
it doesn't mean anything where's the
replacement that means we don't know
right it doesn't mean that anybody's in
a position to tell you that it's safe
yep
and no one seems to be um upset by the
fact that there apparently is if if we
take them with their word there's just
no system i just have no idea
so i did finally manage to wrestle up
this screenshot
which you can show here zach what this
is
uh is uh from the letter that was sent
to the parents of this elite athlete in
cross country who's who's you know not
highly nationally ranked
and the message that was sent says in in
august we communicated with you that it
was likely that the kobit 19 vaccine
would be authorized for use in younger
children at some point during the
cross-country season
as of yesterday that prediction has come
true so i think his son is actually 11.
therefore in keeping with the policy
that the board communicated to you we
will be requiring vaccination for our
athletes and coaches who are all already
vaccinated now that everyone is eligible
to receive the vaccine
the same week that we um
we previously communicated with you the
venues at which we compete for indoor
track began recording vaccination for
entry to those venues and keeping with
the nyc's policies for anyone 12 and
older
including parents and coaches there is
no longer a test out option in place
so the
the onerous um but doable for for people
um option that many places have now is
you have to show proof of vaccination or
you know a negative test within 24 48 72
hours i've seen all of those
uh has been taken away and um i couldn't
i'm not sure in the whole thing here
because i thought it was giving away
some identifying stuff but this is
uh basically the the athlete himself
will need to be vaccinated if he's going
to participate um and because his
parents are unwilling having done the
analysis for themselves and for their
family to take that risk for their very
healthy
young son
um need to pull him feel that they need
to pull him from competing uh in the
sport in which he is um
excellent
and
finding you know skill and confidence
and a social life and you know
everything else that we would hope
that activities
uh can do for our children
has to pull him because he has made the
very difficult choice uh being he's
forced
to make the very difficult choice do i
take away from my child
this huge part of his life at which he
is excelling
or put him at
risk
for something that uh i think is uh too
onerous and am i recalling correctly one
of the parents is an md i think yeah you
said that so what we have here is a
situation in which
a
uh a mandate is being handed down
by an authority in which a parent who is
an md who has
the child's best interests at heart and
is attempting to protect the child from
presumably covid and other things that
threaten the child like
bad pharmaceuticals
and this parent has made this decision
and the top down authority is going to
override the parent or force the parent
to make this decision in spite of the
fact that
there's no way this authority can
demonstrate a threat to a healthy child
because that has actually been looked
into
right the fact is healthy children are
not at serious risk yeah whereas
quite a number have died from vaccines
[Music]
you